let's talk about why him a very funny  movie very funny would be great cast you  got you you got  Bryan Cranston you guys seem to have a  very good chemistry together yeah it  goes in there yeah we got to do this one  scene in the movie where you guys get  pretty down and dirty yeah I get him in  let his head in a leg lock at one point  and I got strong legs so when you're in  when you get once you're in there's no  gettin out  why would one want to get out yeah why  would you want to yeah happy to be in  that jail that's my technique never  worked we have a clip here and I believe  this is the scene where you see Laird  who is in a club is that right there it  is James Franco's character and he's  he's being very friendly let's take a  look at his clip  and then the holiday spirit  [Music]  he ate it  [Applause]  you